you could be talking about a million
topics but you're missing
what's happening in the cultural
conversation when you master trend
surfing
when you understand how to spot trends
and then
quickly start paddling and putting in
the energy to ride that wave
it can change everything did you know
that there are specific videos that if
you make them
they can blow up your youtube channel
not even just blow up your youtube
channel
but you can get more views and
subscribers and really build
authority in your niche and
if you are looking for those specific
videos then i recommend that you lean
into today's episode
if you feel like you're struggling with
trying to figure out what videos should
you make next
then this is the episode for you we're
starting a two-part series
where we're going to be sharing with you
the videos that you should be looking
for
in your niche if you're trying to blow
up your channel
my name is heather torres and you are
listening to the think media podcast
the number one podcast to help you grow
your influence
on youtube and then turn that influence
into a high profit
and a high impact youtube channel if
you're brand new to
this podcast we want to welcome you and
if you are returning
thanks for coming back we love seeing
our think community over here
on the podcast well in today's first
part we're going to be diving into
how to find videos that are going to
help your channel grow
sean's going to be breaking this down in
a two-parter so lean in because this
is the video for you if you're stuck
on youtube if you're not getting views
if you can't figure out how to grow
this is the video for you well let's
jump into today's featured conversation
and i'll be telling you at the end about
something you need to do
for five days
[Music]
have you ever been surfing i don't know
maybe you've seen people surfing in
movies or surfing on social media
somewhere
maybe if you grew up on a coast you grew
up surfing or maybe you did it once on a
vacation
for me i didn't really grow up surfing i
grew up in the northwest so
skateboarding and snowboarding was my
thing
but as far as surfing goes it was a
little too cold unless you wore
a wetsuit and i didn't really want to
wear a wetsuit up in
seattle but eventually i had the
opportunity later in life to hang out
with my friend jeff morse who lives in
oceanside
california he's a local church pastor
church planter
and he's really into surfing so he one
day he wanted to take me surfing now
there was other things i wanted to do
you know eat uh
sleep in um a lot of other things in
fact but but he's like come on bro let's
go surfing so he got me the biggest
spongiest
longboard possible um he's a ripper he
can get onto those little short boards
and we went out to the pier and we went
out to the
the beach at oceanside california and we
we started to surf
and um it was awful i mean i it might
have been the worst day of my life
for a lot of reasons i mean number one i
didn't have the skill to surf uh
number two i haven't really built the
strength to surf so i'm
you know salt water is in my eyes my
eyes are burning i'm swimming out to the
the waves my arms are already tired and
we're three minutes into it so as i
start to try to get up and catch waves
and fall down and swim back out
i'm getting really fatigued quickly and
what you need to really do is kind of do
a push-up
simultaneous as you're catching the wave
and so i'm just getting hammered by
waves i can't really ever stand up
my longest wave i rode was like that's
two seconds before falling
um it was it was pretty traumatic i mean
honestly and i
maybe if i stuck with it um i could
develop that skill but even that's
pretty doubtful
um and uh you know that's that's the
story but here's
an insight that i got about youtube um
when
surfing in oceanside with jeff is i
would watch
how he would do things and he was super
fit so he would just swim right out past
the waves
he'd turn around sit on his board and
then he'd watch
he'd watch for coming waves he'd watch
for the right wave
at the right time and then he would
start to paddle
he would then pop up on his board and he
would ride
that wave that he spotted for as long as
it lasted and that was his goal was to
to catch the right waves that would give
you you know a nice
uh long-lasting wave with the right curl
this is not an official term i'm sorry
for offending the surfers you know with
the right you don't want the white water
but you want it
cresting right okay i'll leave it there
but you know so he would catch these
waves and then he'd swim back out
and he would catch another one what i
thought about was i thought about this
is really
one of the best strategies on youtube
that we talk about and
we call it trend surfing trend surfing i
heard it said by one person that really
winning on youtube is about
understanding human psychology
and spotting trends and so when i think
about trend surfing it's this idea that
you're sitting on the waves you're
positioned
you know you're not on the beach you're
not on the sidelines you're ready
to create content you're ready to hit
record you're ready
to make a video but you're also just
kind of sitting there waiting and
strategically
looking at what are the trends what are
the things that are happening what
trends what
waves are coming and when a wave starts
to come when it's a good wave
see what will happen for jeff is when
he's at home he might have planned to
just chill at home in the morning and
drink coffee
but he looks at the weather report and
he's like oh man it's going to be a good
day
oh the swell is going to be good today
man i got to get down to the beach and i
got to hit the waves
smart youtube creators when they spot
trends when they see a wave beginning
they've developed a skill to see a trend
coming they've developed the develop the
skill to jump on the trend quickly
they've developed the skill to ride the
trend why it is present
and then they've developed the skill to
swim back out and catch
another trend you know the truth is the
creator who understands the viewer best
wins on youtube and the best creators
know what
viewers want but here's your objection
you might say sean
like is trends just do i should i just
make random
trendy content that's not what i'm
talking about i'm not talking about just
being off brand neglecting the value
proposition or the niche or the niche of
your channel
no i'm actually talking about tying
trends into
your content your goal is to talk about
the timely topics
that people are thinking about in the
moment related to your
niche the best surfers are not catching
every wave
they're catching the right waves that
they know how to ride that are going to
work best with their board their style
their skills
so you want to be looking at what trends
related or adjacent
to my industry could i catch what's some
examples of trend surfing
well here's one erica kohlberg has a
personal finance channel she's also a
lawyer
and that's her background and she's
really grown quickly over 100 000
subscribers
she actually got a lot of press and
media because of how quickly she grew
so one of the things she was doing on
her channel was not just a video
on how to save how to invest
how to get out of debt those are good
questions but those are pretty
a lot of people have answered those
questions you should answer specific
questions
but what she did was especially during
the
pandemic there was the whole stimulus
conversation
and a lot of people were searching
looking for
information about stimulus checks who
qualifies the fine print the details
and she made multiple videos about
stimulus checks
specifically and almost single-handedly
those videos put her on the map you are
one successful
surfing trip on a trend away
from building your youtube channel to a
really high level maybe even a silver
play button and over a hundred thousand
subscribers
i think about think media and a lot of
opportunities
came out of the pandemic now listen i'm
not trying to be insensitive
i'm not negating all of the pain and
lingering pain that happened during that
time
but our spirit and mentality at think
media
is not to just sit on the sidelines
we're empathetic to the problems but we
also want to serve and solve
problems in the midst of challenging
situations
because the pandemic made you have to
figure out how to homeschool and stay
home and maybe
disrupted your job so we're here to say
well actually
in every problem is hidden opportunity
the pro the opportunity to pivot the
opportunity to figure out how to build a
business from home
so one of the videos we made during the
pandemic was how to use your phone
as a webcam on zoom so people they're
locked down
now it's remote work now it's
teleconferencing that is a trend a
massive
trend i mean some of these trends we're
talking about the search volume the
interest volume
skyrocketed through the roof because all
of a sudden everyone's at home
there's also a back order for a lot of a
lot of 2020 there was back orders on
webcams and all kinds of other things
so someone already has their laptop they
already have
a phone so make a video on how to use a
webcam
with when using zoom and the video just
blows
up on its way to a million views because
we were
trend surfing what are people
thinking about in your industry or
related to your industry that would
attract the right viewers to your
channel
what are the timely topics that you
could be talking about
vitali one of our video ranking academy
students and inner circle students
um has a channel called succeed in r e
i that's real estate investing and he's
an attorney and he explains
he did a video explaining the e i
d l loans and the contract documents for
the small business loans given out
because of the pandemic again
kind of similar to erica that video on
his channel got 236
000 views his audience small business
owners real estate investors
using his skill set jumping on the
actual topics people are talking about
now hear me
this strategy is worth its weight in
gold if you apply it
because again you might just be checking
the box and making just
general videos answering questions which
is a good
kind of day-to-day method of posting
content on youtube
but if you really want to trigger
massive growth and results
lean into trend surfing calm your mind
sit on the waves observe culture
observe what's happening in the society
in society around you
what is your target audience thinking
about what do they want to know about
everybody in erica's audience and people
she didn't know yet they wanted to know
about stimulus checks
vitale they wanted to know about these
small business loans
um there was a a few years back one of
the huge trends
in kind of more of the entertainment or
diy was people
when harry potter was really crushing in
terms of the movies being released
people wanted to do diy
wizard wands the harry potter wands so i
looked up a video
easy step-by-step harry potter diy
wizard1 from paper
this channel has 3 000 subscribers maybe
you can relate maybe you're on your way
to your first 1 000 subscribers or
you're under 10
000 subscribers but they posted that
video
123 000 views
so if it's a diy crafts channel you
could say how to make a magic wand
with paper probably not going to do
amazing but you tie into
a movie you tie into what people are
searching about you tie
into a trend like harry potter and all
of a sudden
you have 30x 100x your subscriber count
in terms of views and your channel is
growing because of trend surfing
think about the cryptocurrency niche or
dogecoin or elon musk
people are talking about these
characters all the time getting massive
views
because they're in the cultural
conversation one of our video ranking
academy students bobby eberly
covers conservative news or news from a
conservative perspective he just got a
silver play button because he's able to
cover
trending topics in politics by the way
that's kind of a secret there
imagine if you don't just use trend
surfing for one video
but imagine if you actually built your
channel
around trend surfing which is
essentially what bob everly did
think about cooking maybe it's a
seasonal dish maybe it's a certain
barbecue style that's popular
bulletproof coffee was a huge trend
years ago and this is kind of
one of my passions i watch a lot of this
content on youtube kind of like
bio hacking weird supplements and
tinctures
and powders and bcas and all kinds of
different things my wife sonia it's like
a real problem she's like why
did four more jars of vitamins and
supplements show up to our house we
already have 800
on the counter top and sean i'm a little
bit frustrated and i'm like okay call
the marriage counselor but i actually am
ordering some other stuff that's a true
story this bulletproof coffee thing
i just ordered on sale a whole bunch
more stuff from bulletproof
glutathione zinc with copper
a d k all combined in one because to get
your d vitamin you actually want k
and a related to it she's like do you
need these i'm like yes
honey i need these but as i
get more focused on the examples we're
sharing years ago all of a sudden people
were like what
people are putting butter and mct oil in
their coffee this is crazy
turns out that it actually can be a way
to curb hunger and give yourself some
energy and even lose weight in the
morning
and of course people have different
opinions in the health industry but it
was a massive trend when it was big it
was massive
so if you're talking about fitness
you're talking to entrepreneurs who want
to go to high performance
you're talking about things you could be
talking about a million topics
but you're missing what's happening in
the cultural conversation
when you master trend surfing when you
understand how to spot trends
and then quickly start paddling and
putting in the energy to ride that wave
it can change everything entertainment i
mean if you think about youtube in
itself if you have an entertainment
uh type of channel challenges on youtube
not challenges like our five-day
youtube challenge which if you haven't
been a part of one of those you gotta
definitely sign up
but challenges on youtube they call them
like if you remember planking
like it even ended up in like the office
or different shows
or parks and rec you know uh there's a
watermelon with mustard challenge
you know what i mean have you seen that
like boyfriend does girlfriend's makeup
challenge like these are different
challenges
but when these challenges are happening
that is trend surfing
it's what's happening if you look at
we're talking about youtube but even on
tick tock when
songs are trending when when everyone is
you know i got my driver's license last
week
like we always talk about you know what
i'm talking about if you don't know what
i'm saying i'm gonna leave it there
but olivia rodrigo or i hope i said her
name right like
you know when the songs are trending
people start writing that trend
well challenges on youtube can sometimes
be that and if you have an entertainment
channel you absolutely
can be doing trend surfing in that way
or maybe there's a trending game if
you're in gaming
there's a maybe it's a challenge in a
game some people are like they play a
certain game
only using voice commands and not a
remote or a controller like different
handicaps or things like that that that
people start doing or certain speed runs
and trying to beat other other people's
speed range
you use trend surfing right and you're
one video away from changing your life
and business with youtube and so i want
to share
my favorite tools that i use for
spotting trends but ask yourself this
question
what does your audience want to see what
is a trending topic you can cover that
is relevant to your niche and your
channel
and again this is really a million
dollar idea what if your channel was
based
around trending topics what do you mean
sean again
when you think about bobby ebberly or
like news channels or commentary
channels or react channels
they're constantly feeding off of trends
and culture
how could you strategically incorporate
that maybe into your
upload schedule well sean how do i spot
trends well one way is youtube.com
forward slash trending
now this isn't my favorite way for
probably most of us in the think media
podcast community
because what you're going to see here is
a lot of music videos
a lot of the biggest youtube creators
with these larger than life types of
videos and
you know creators that sometimes have a
team of 100 people
and huge budgets which is all fine and
and by all means you might spot some
unique indie creators or new up and
comers
so it's definitely a page worth checking
out youtube.com force
for its last trending maybe there's a
video you can react to
maybe you react to it from a business
perspective a faith perspective a
spiritual perspective
a personal finance perspective a cooking
perspective a chef a scientific
perspective a health perspective like
whatever your niche
what's on that page that you could maybe
tie into another one is google
trends you can compare and contrast how
much influence trends
really have think about it this way on
think media we sometimes say
what cameras should we cover next and
we'll type in the canon m50 on google
trends
select youtube results we'll type in the
sony a600 on google trends
we'll type in a couple different and you
can compare and contrast
which cameras have the most the biggest
wave
the biggest the most traffic behind them
and then make decisions
about which videos we're going to make
that's my friend jeff sitting on the
water
catching the right wave because you only
have so much time in a day
you're going to make and try to make at
least one video a week to the degree
that the topic of that video
makes a real impact is how quickly
you're going to reach your youtube goals
another one is google news i like to
type in my topics on google news
that i like to cover and just see what
are the latest articles what are the
latest headlines
about the creator economy or what are
the latest headlines about youtube
that's my
industry have you typed in your industry
on google news to see
what are the latest trends or things
that are happening or
news that is broken number four any
industry-leading publications or blogs
that are specific to your market
you know you can set up notifications on
your mac or pc
so that you get notifications from the
blogs that matter
to you like for us at think media this
is like sony rumors canon rumors
video maker no film school and again
a lot of these headlines might come at
me and i'm like that's not relevant no
big deal you just kind of glance over
them daily or whatever
but sometimes it's like sony releasing a
brand new camera for vloggers i'm like
oh man it's time for us to take action
and jump on that you want to make sure
you've set up a flow of information
coming your way
if you want to use trend surfing
strategically
to grow your channel number five is
following other
industry experts or other experts in
your industry
you know there's so much noise and
information
and even in your niche within a niche
within a niche it's hard to stay up on
what's happening in your industry so one
of the powerful things to do
is follow people strategically on social
media not just meme accounts
unless you have a meme channel not just
uh
you know random accounts that are not
helping you that are based on humor or
whatever
but what if you follow people that will
bring information to you because they're
valuable social media channels so you're
not just scrolling looking for mindless
entertainment
but you have strategic people or
brand accounts delivering information
right to your social media feed
and and the sixth tip is kind of the
same is curating your social media
accounts that you follow
what if you set up your social media so
that relevant information flows
to you i want to encourage you that this
isn't the only strategy that you need in
your tool belt
this is just one of many tools
and i also want to encourage you this is
why you need to get to grow a video live
this year
it's a virtual event it's two days and
we're not just going to be going deeper
on topics like trend surfing we're going
to be talking about
tools like this which is the difference
between those that stay stuck on youtube
and those that really scale and build a
profitable youtube business
that gets massive views and master
massive subscribers you need tools in
your tool belt
and trend surfing is one of those
tools and when you use it wisely at the
right
time it can trigger massive growth
and views for your channel so i
encourage you try
trend surfing out on your next video
well i hope that that started to spark
some ideas i know as sean was going
through it i was thinking of ideas that
we could be doing here on the think
media podcast writing some trends in our
niche that we haven't even done yet so
stay tuned because more episodes are
coming just like this and i want to ask
you
what's your step that you need to take
do you have a video that you could make
do you have a trend maybe you need to
follow someone in your niche or like
sean said
start looking up google trends to see
what is actually happening in your niche
for me personally on my home school
channel i remember when the pandemic hit
it was like people wanted to figure out
how do i start homeschooling so i jumped
in and i made that video and i'm so
grateful that i did
that video has now led to several
different podcast interviews
because i rode the trend so what trend
can you ride
what does this look like for you and
what video can you
make next now i told you at the
beginning of this episode that there was
something you need to do for five days
and
that is our tube 1k challenge we have a
brand new
free live interactive challenge where we
are going to be helping you get to your
first
1000 subscribers and beyond this is a
five day challenge that you can take for
free
and then at the end we're gonna help you
go deeper
on youtube i highly recommend that you
go to tube1kchallenge.com
to get signed up and registered and then
share it with a friend
who can you take this challenge with
we've seen so many testimonials of
people who have gone through
our other challenges and this one is
fresh with brand new content that's
going to help you get to your first
1000 subscribers you can register today
at
tube1kchallenge.com okay my favorite
thing
every single week is reading your
reviews
on apple itunes now if you go or apple
podcast
if you go over there and rate and review
the podcast we're able to read those
here and i get to see more of our think
community it's my favorite thing to do
to read comments on youtube
read comments on the apple itunes and or
not itunes is a podcast it's apple
podcast right well anyways
this is arden arden says think media
foundations builder
maximizer yeah i want to make a podcast
about that artist
think media podcasts are fabulous
informat information
and application interesting and
wonderful content
and presentation the things being taught
in the manner of presentation
make this a great place to learn and
grow make your own channel
more valuable what they give you is
directly applicable
to your own use and growth very topical
funny and entertaining this is for you
thanks sean and heather well arden
thanks for being a part of our think
community
and what an amazing testimonial and just
comment that you left there for us
i'm so grateful to have people like you
inside of our community
we do we try and make it topical and
funny and entertaining i mean
sean sang driver's license on this one
you don't get that
everywhere folks so really fun to have
you as part of our think community and
we're grateful that
you are rating and reviewing and sharing
this podcast well
in the next week's episode we're going
to go into part two and in part two
sean's going to be breaking down what do
you do once you make the video
and it starts taking off what's the next
thing that you should do
on your youtube channel he's gonna be
breaking that down because we've got
case studies from ourselves
and our community of what we've done
when a video
that we are trend surfing starts to blow
up well
thanks for being on today's episode and
we will catch you
in the next one bye want to learn how
everyday people are starting youtube
channels and making incredible
income online learn the proven steps and
newest strategies at the grow with video
live virtual
two day conference get your ticket today
at growethvideolive.com
[Music]
you